hello and welcome to las vegas' side in
spanish our digital connection to the
world of entertainment here in las
vegas' greets you natalia bad sound
we start this segment with a lot of
flavor and a great announcement by the
gentleman of salsa better known
as  Gilberto Santa Rósa and it is that he
will bring his walking tour or lodge hotel
here in Las Vegas on Sunday
November 14 the cost of tickets
start at 75 dollars and are
available via the excess
reggaeton salsa dotcom curiosity will not
kill us this time  because jay weaver and
favorite voice will emerge show in his
show to las vegas s will be performing at
the chelsea theater inside the cosmopolitan
from november 26 tickets start
at $30 and go on sale
friday november 15 via
cosmopolitan las  vegas' dotcom
we only change the musical genre and it
is that the red hot chilli peppers are
coming stereo audition our next
summer for this stop is a  of the
several that are part of their
2022 world tour where the press will
perform with the strokes and kim
clijsters tickets go on sale this
friday morning
and the legendary rock band tex
will kick off their 50th anniversary
here  in las vegas and they will do it through
an intimate commitment of five nights in
the isr workshop tickets for these
shows that will take place during the month of
january and february also go on sale
this friday
and comedy music and I joined to
entertain  a special night at the mirage this
november 4 with a show titled
broadcast and friends where
their comedy acts will be presented along with other
special guests who for the
moment remain anonymous tickets and
are on sale through
ticketmaster.com
well let's go on a  tour of fears and
let's talk about the holidays and it is that the
chocolate shop
announced the return of its
Christmas lights to the garden of cactus eye you must
make a reservation before
attending  Go to this event and keep in mind
that they will ask you for a minimum donation of 5
dollars which will benefit 34 food
bank. For more information visit fm
dotcom
I'm talking about the Christmas season get
your ice skates ready because
the cosmopolitan ice rink returns to  Las
Vegas' for its tenth consecutive year, in
addition to ice skating,
you can also enjoy other experiences such
as snacks and special drinks,
Christmas movies and more. The
ice rink will open its doors on Tuesday,
November 16 until January 2 of
next year
.  Up to here it came, rather, the
edition of the regattas in Spanish.
Do not forget to visit the snap dotcom in
case you need to know more about all those
stories. See you next week,
Natalia Marcelina greets you
[Music]